Okay,
well I could talk.
Let me talk about the situation at the
Ivy League universities.
First,
the question broadly speaking covers the
question about intelligence and about
its diverse manifestations and about its
role in selection for universities.
Could go back and look at the records at
Harvard for example,
in the early 19 sixties,
the typical IQ for a Harvard student was
about 100,
five to 110,
not much above average,
but that's because they were finishing
schools for the,
for the rich,
roughly speaking,
and you know your.
If you had a rich father and he made his
money,
he was probably well above average in
intelligence,
but if you are his offspring,
there's regression towards the mean,
so there's no reason to assume that by
nature of your position you are going to
be particularly intelligent anyways.
The average Ivy League student wasn't,
was bright but not outstanding.
So now it's 100 IQ,
145,
three standard deviations above the mean
because.
And the reason for that is because
they're selected by the sat scholastic
aptitude test.
It's an IQ test.
They won't say it's an IQ test,
but that doesn't matter.
It isn't.
It's an IQ test.
It's a simple as that.
Any any test that contains a
sufficiently diverse range of problem
solving questions that's rank ordered
in,
in accuracy among people is an IQ test.
The correlations like point eight,
five.
So and what has happened.
There's two things that have happened.
I mean the Ivy Leagues have got more and
more selective because they can and so
the average IQ of their students is just
continued to move upwards and then the
average IQ of the population is actually
increased to a substantive degree to
over the last 50 years.
Partly because partly perhaps mostly
because of improved nutrition and and
information exposure along among the.
Like the more deprived members of the
culture.
It's better to watch tv than to sit
alone in your crib for example,
an isolated and people have enough food
now.
So the really low end of the
intelligence spectrum is being truncated
and the general population IQ is
increased.
So with regards to institutions like the
University of Toronto,
say they average IQ at the University of
Toronto with somewhere between 120 130,
and we know that because we've tested it
and it's not surprising because you're
basically selected for cognitive
process,
right?
Because grades are rough.
Marker of intelligence.
Conscientiousness,
by the way also matters independent
trait because the best two predictors of
university grades are conscientiousness
and intelligence,
not creativity,
by the way,
zero correlation with creativity.